hey guys I'm Ryan right hey there I'm
Veronica six does we're gonna watch the
trailer today for a Night at the Museum
dress this time they're going to a
museum in Mexico I'm not falling ah yes
falling yes in these movies going
together well since you know I think
about it it's about you security guard
oh we're excited Museum and [ __ ] come
Celina you know that that's what you
said to me earlier it's been approved
for Jewish audiences the greatest
discovery in 3,000 years will then cover
the origin of a secret program and lead
history's greatest heroes were they've
never gone before you are speaking with
a pharaoh kiss my stuff oh is it okay if
I don't hey you and I both know there's
something magical when you see Sun Goes
Down tablet starts to glow everything
comes to life this Christmas yes we look
similar no no I'm not your Dada no touch
stop it the magic is running out there's
nothing wrong with the tablet we shall
all be dead by Sunrise unstart
hyperventilate under- with their
greatest adventure these guys depend on
me how so just begun we have to go to
London to figure this out
Hey welcome to the British Museum people
could be in a security guard in America
with your gun with the silencer with
your ninja swords I want you to stay
here and make sure nobody comes in or
out
oh [ __ ]
President of the United States of
America I have no idea what that means
Oh
aren't you take a picture and last
longer night at the Museum
secret of the tomb
Oh gross oh it's fun doesn't look fun
it's cute and fun I would like that I
think you'll like it a lot too I think
we should both go together
he doesn't never invite me to the movies
I don't everyone write anyone's in
movies except for Alyssa Kat Lauren
Sally
Marie Jerry dan and I are fine going
Jeremy and I have gone a few times
that's it really
that's probably all very true are you
talking about all of your friends we saw
malefic come together that for me it's
not eita wife ever forgive me for my
trespasses
this movie looks fun I was okay I was
okay you just saying everything that I
say I'm doing I've said that to you know
so your subscribers think that I just
copy everything that you say which is
totally not sugar because I know it's
like that on and off camera I like the
first one the second one was a lot more
fun in my opinion and this one I'm like
it's something about it seems like
you're kind of phoning it in but it
another part of me is like this still
looks pretty interesting though and I
get it a day it's supposed to be for
families and kids alike so yeah it looks
like it's gonna deliver on the goods
basically my cheeks my family I created
spider-man anyway guys thanks for
telling me of that trailer was out I
liked in the Night at the Museum
franchise despite the reviews on Rotten
Tomatoes if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe right here
and Veronica has a channel too does a
lot of beautiful scene and a vlog that
is really an adventure of Veronica's
life and soon she'll be covering the sex
positions she favors the most so
subscribe rate that's not actually true
no you can put it in everybody let's do
some shout outs read
Veronica that was caught your vagina you
were gonna call me Victoria
no this abj me know as I say V Jane
Victoria I was like yeah hey what's up
my name is Veronica yeah okay yeah some
people call me Brian like similar story
I was at the grocery store here my name
Brian turn around my family
turn around if my whole family says s s
what saala oh three nine five hey Ryan
home bro I've never heard that word
before home bro what does that mean
it's kind of like I'm sure there's a
reference there and you're like my
shoulder man I'm not actually asking for
a shout-out but if I did get the number
one then you would would without a doubt
be all be my all-time favorite Martin
love you bro and Elissa god you're
gorgeous don't worry a lot of yous
Alyssa people are complimenting you I
just just yeah were you coming at the
end like you couldn't control it like I
was like is like I was jerking you off
and you were like no don't do this this
feels wrong I'm not gay and then I was
doing anything you started getting an
erection and then you got like so turned
on you're like I just I just oh can you
come and I'm like see you are there's
your shoutout Giovanni Rivera I don't
think you're gonna like this comment I
totally forgot to mention you can i have
a shout out please
you guys are awesome until jerry he is
legit
that means legal Murray is sweet sure
Sally is cute
yes very good days dad is awesome and
you sir Ryan are all of those things
combined well thanks yeah I'll agree
with that
oh and tell us I said hi you're kind of
a douche though for not mentioning
Lauren and Veronica where are they why
weren't they mentioned to me she's right
here what up [ __ ] you dick seriously if
I meet this guy in real life I'm gonna
kick his [ __ ] ass or you must cry yes
you've been really sad yeah well well
thank you for your Bonnie Rivera thank
you
shout-out is done for you too Matthew
McEwan hey can I get a shout-out
you guys are so entertaining to watch
when there's nothing to do
keep up the good work when I got nothing
to do when I'm bored you guys are pretty
entertaining actually if he said
especially when there's nothing into it
he didn't say it's like literally I got
nothing to do then I'm I want usually
any other option is better
hi Matthew yeah that's great okay well
guys this has been the shoutouts
Matthew McEwan you're entertaining to
watch when I'm bored Mickey isn't even
we really just thinking that you just
say that and I was really thinking yeah
it's like looking at you I was like [ __ ]
you're really hot really yeah oh this
videos done I just want to talk about
this mmm what are we gonna do with this
what are we gonna do with this feeling I
have about you being odd I mean we got
we got to resolve it somehow what's
gonna happen when the camera turns up